I'm Michael Warner and I'm just acting
as moderator here let me introduce our
panel which is really wonderful people
start with Steven Johnson who's the
editor of the book I trusted you all
those right outside Steven Johnson and
state avoid and Julie these are all
stars in the world of new media
criticism and commentary so they
probably require very little
introduction and I thought I might begin
by just making an observation about the
book that we've got here which is that
in some ways if you look at the title
best technology writing you might you
might pick it up expecting articles on
improvements in automotive design or how
to build a nuclear bomb in your dorm
room but in fact with I think only one
exception it's all the others are really
about digital media so the book might as
well I've been called best digital media
writing 2009 and I don't think we would
have a very different book so I thought
I'd begin by asking Stephen a little bit
about how that came about and what he
thinks is is interesting about that fact
thank you Michael it's this fun to be
here you know it's funny I was talking
to to Julian we did a Connecticut public
radio call-in radio show this morning
from New York actually and and Julie
made the similar observation that you
know you kind of said you know it's
interesting it's really it's it's only
about digital media it's not about other
forms of technology and I did have a
momir or I thought wait there are other
forms of technology yeah they kind of go
through my head
what are the oh right yeah I guess there
are so I think there are two reasons the
first is you know when you added
something your own kind of interests and
passions inevitably kind of shape a
little bit of your selection criteria
but the other thing that I think it's
worth pointing out is which is which is
a kind of recurring theme of the whole
book is the speed with which digital
media's is evolving and the speed with
which we are coming up with kind of new
uses and integrations for it in our in
our daily lives and so just on some
basic level I think it's a reasonable
statement to say that there's just more
activity and there's and there's more if
you're talking about the kind of social
consequences of new technology there's
just more news kind of coming out of
digital media and more reasons kind of
for reflection and and and maybe one of
the best examples of it is there's
there's a wonderful piece by Clive
Thompson in in the essay that he wrote
for The Times Magazine that's that's
basically about Facebook and to some
extent about Twitter and and it's really
about this idea of kind of status
updates and ambient awareness you're
kind of general the feeling of like yeah
I kind of know what my friend had for
breakfast and it's it's not really news
but it's kind of interesting in a nice
way to kind of keep this background kind
of following of these people anything
but that was an essay I ran kind of a
year and a half ago and it was a very
smart essay and it had a lot of great
observations and is still useful but
there was no hint there of you know
Twitter and the Iranian elections at all
in the theory of kind of social media
there so you can just see right there
the speed with which these things are
getting kind of absorbed by us and put
two new uses almost immediately so
there's just there's so much to say I
think about that whereas you know as
much as we would like green technology
to advance faster I it isn't moving
quite as fast i would say not being an
expert but saying as an amateur as as
the digital media landscape is and so I
think that's one of the reasons why you
you have that focus
I said that all these people are big
enough stars in the certain world that
they probably don't need introductions
but maybe I should introduce some little
anyway Steven Johnson you know the
author of many best-selling and highly
regarded books the one that I know best
is the ghost map because he came and
visited the research center that I used
to run at Rutgers after the ghost map
came out the ghost map is a really
brilliant study of the cholera epidemic
in London in the middle of the 19th
century and what it tells us about
urbanity and urban life in general Dana
did a dissertation on social computing
is that correct it is social media at
Berkeley and now works between Microsoft
and Harvard Julian is a graduate of Yale
and made he was telling me in fact that
he had 125 with trogot Lawler who is
teaching 125 this year and yes exactly
we didn't damage him and he's also as
many of you know that no author of a
number of classic articles in the study
of the Internet including rape and
cyberspace and and several others and
jack balkin who teaches in the law
school and runs the balkanization blog
and is a leading scholar and expert and
organizer in the area of internet law so
I thought since a couple of you have
English department connection
and since we are in in an English
department room i thought i'd ask the
question is dominant on my mind which is
this book tells us so much about what
about how to think of digital literacy
and it gives us so many reasons for
distrusting our ready-made beliefs that
we already know what that is so Stevens
introduction which I highly recommend to
everybody it's a really terrific piece
explaining the insights of the book
Stevens introduction begins by observing
that when people were writing about the
internet 10 years ago was all future
oriented it was all predictive what's
going to happen to the world now being
organized by hypertext and it turns out
that most of the predictions were wrong
the most of the essays in this book
observes are about just describing the
complexity of present-day uses of the
internet so there's no hyperventilating
about the future there's just an attempt
to try to be faithful to the
extraordinary range and complexity of
what people are actually doing so we
seemed in some ways to have lost or
given up on the apparent clarity of a
concept like digital literacy as though
we know what that means but we're
getting much more detailed understanding
of how these media are shaping up in
actual practice and the kinds of social
worlds that people are building out go
just say one thing to start in the night
but the others talk but I think you know
one of the clearest examples of that is
is there's an essay we put in there by
nicholas carr called is google making us
stupid and it was it's very smart and
and engaging essay i disagree with a
bunch of it but it was one of those
essays you kind of enjoy
he learned disagreeing with it and it
was a kind of a healthy contribution I
think to the to the debate on a couple
of fronts and what Nick was saying this
piece is that he can he can feel when he
sits down to read a book you know the
old-fashioned kind without a screen
attached to it that he can feel this
kind of lateral pull of of you know kind
of hyper textin and gmail and and
Twitter and all these things that he
knows is sitting there across the room
on the screen and he feel his brain
having kind of acclimation to the to the
life on the screen being unable to check
on focus in the same way and to get into
that kind of immersive kind of linear
focus that traditional reading was
supposed to be about and so he could
have built this argument about kind of
the Google landscape kind of dumbing us
down and I think you know on the one
hand I feel that too there are any of it
as you said that our predictions about
this stuff when I was sitting around
thinking about what hypertext was going
to be like in the early 90s I went to
brown as an undergrad and we were doing
a lot of kind of innovative work back
then Dana what to brown as well in
hypertext fiction and before the web
came around it it's hard to remember
this now but ninety-eight percent of the
innovation and hyper Dex was
experimental fiction authors or poetry
authors who were presently who are
talking about how this was going to
revolutionize narrative and you would
you know read narrative in this
nonlinear way and you choose one path or
another and you construct hopscotch
style your stories out of these
hypertext branching paths and it turned
out that hypertext became vastly more
mainstream than anybody ever dreamed you
know even the most over-the-top
advocates for it never thought that you
know my 96 year old grandmother would be
clicking on links the way she does every
day now but nonlinear narrative
storytelling turned out to have nothing
to do with this hypertext um and and its
remains basically as marginal and
experimental as it was then I hope I'm
not insulting any much in the audience
but I it has not we still sit there and
read you know Dan Brown novels one page
after the other but hypertext went
mainstream in all these other ways and
so what the irony of it is it turns out
then once you're in the kind of present
tense of these media forms going fully
mainstreaming
integrated with a culture that all these
unpredictable things happen and that
part of your work as a critic and it's a
writer is not to you know project
forward into the future but rather to
just watch yourself or the watch people
around you as these new forms become
kind of mainstream and what ended up
happening I think in that you can see in
in the case of Nick's essay and with
Google it's not that our books became
nonlinear but that when we sit down to
read them now we feel this kind of weird
withdrawal from our normal nonlinear
experience moving around the web and so
we missed the links it's not that
they're links there it's just that we
wish they were there on some level and
that means I think finally to kind of
sum it up is it's true i think what nick
says it's a trade-off though and it's a
trade-off that i think a lot of us have
kind of willingly made that we
understand that it's harder to read 400
consecutive pages and it was when i was
in grad school said before the web came
along on the other hand there's so much
that you get out of the immersion in
these things in these new forms that
despite all the overload and despite all
the distractions we're willing to kind
of make that trade-off because of all
the benefits i would take a slightly
different tactic and i say over and over
against is the beginning of all of us
we've enjoyed adding digital or e or
cyber to a whole variety of things we
thought we understood and the result of
wishes we get obsessed with the
technology right so digital literacies
all about the technology when in fact
what we're seeing is that we have to
complicate what the digital does is it
complicates our understanding of say
literacy in this case and the same
things that are starting to apply the
thing the kinds of thinking that we have
to do for things like literacy you know
what we had to do because of the digital
actually apply back and so what's ends
up happening is we have this move that
happens where first it's all about the
digital it's all about the digital and
slowly the digital
the way and so when I think about you
know your question about digital
literacy I think that the most is soo
salient aspect of it is what's happening
to literacy how do we think about
literacy and what is what is the shift
in technology and the introduction of
all of these new media due to our basic
understandings of literacy and I think
we're certainly seem that in the
classroom but are really interesting
away which is you know of course we're
having everyone wants to introduce media
literacy into the classroom and digital
literacy in the classroom and at first
they mean like familiarity with
technology but all of a sudden you see
that we actually are having hmm what
does it mean to have a source what is it
what kind of bias is baked into whatever
we're reading or consuming how do we
think about the politics in that and the
elements that come together to you know
make this this piece of content and to
all the sudden it becomes a question not
of digital but of literacy at its core
and so I think that there's a really
fascinating move which I think ends up
leaving its way through this whole book
where you know it's a book about in some
ways digital technologies but in many or
digital media but certainly a book about
media and a whole variety of different
things and we've got has our obsession
with the new the new the new are sort of
taking really core things and looking at
some of the ships and the changes but
also I had a core question for each one
of these essays I'm just wondering what
does everyday life look like now so I
had the pleasure to announce that I will
be filling Steven shoes next year with
the best of Technology writing in 2010
and be editing the next year's
collection and and as I was reading
through Stevens introductory essay I was
singing
damn that's a hard act to follow because
it's laid out the the issues around
digital media and and how it's shaping
intellectual discourse and thought
itself so well and then and then the
next essay suddenly presented itself in
the form of the question Michael
precisely asked why is there no other
technology being discussed there
actually believe it or not there are a
couple of essays in here about green
technology about architectural
technology that sort of get it lighted
and and for all of the reasons that
Stephen suggests there's just so much
happening in digital media that makes
for so many stories and makes for such a
kinetic landscape but the question still
needs asking why digital technology why
not the other chef-y bits and not Adams
right it's not as if these are just two
different stories and we're deciding to
tell the digital media story they're
actually two sides of the same stories
interesting on the call-in show today
there there was a caller you know when
you know how it is with a call-in show
you never know what the level of insight
is going to be but somebody managed to
get in the interesting point that you
know the amount of coal that's being
burned to service all of this literate
experimentation is is really quite
phenomenal the two questions are length
I came across a great quote the other
day from a theorist of peer to peer
production named Michelle balance who
said we're living at this moment in this
world in a political economy
has it exactly backwards right we think
that the production of the natural world
is completely a limited it's completely
limitless and infinite and we think that
we should be introducing artificial
scarcities into the world of immaterial
production and as we see with the whole
battle around intellectual property
online the two stories are intimately
related and and maybe we're not looking
at that story of you know how do we
develop technology that will save the
world from the impending apocalypse
because it's just an unpleasant story to
look at I mean it's really quite there's
quite a lot of heavy lifting there and
it's not as much fun as Twitter god
knows what I think I just also finally
want to say I think there's also a
little bit of a professional bias here
you know we are we are writers and you
know this is writing a bat attack and I
have always taken it for obvious to the
point where maybe it's not even a useful
observation but it might be in this
context that really the first digital
technology was writing itself if you
think about how writing represents
reality it is the assigning of arbitrary
signal to represent you know what what
is out there in reality supposed to the
analog representation which is a close
you know more physical media supposedly
representation it's just a different
style of representation and and you know
inherited from language itself but
that's you know the whole other topic so
i think we as writers are drawn to
digital technology because it has so
many of the crazy features of
but on steroids I mean it is really you
know so this goes the questions goes to
the debate between Nikolas and Stephen
which is very interesting has good
points on both sides but on both sides
kind of assumes that we really are
talking about a completely new era when
in fact this is a phase shift in a very
long evolution of digital technology
beginning with writing you know there
are moments in Nicholas's piece where
he'll sort of say you know as if
analogizing to the present moment well
you know when writing came along Plato
and Socrates were very suspicious of it
and because it had all these problems
that people we're going to outsource
their memory and they were going to lose
their minds you know in various ways
well now we've seen that it was a
worthwhile trade off but we don't know
about this one well the assumption there
is that you know that gamble was made
and the results are clear and you know
and when printing came along that was a
similar moment and now we know what
happened but in fact we still don't know
what happened because this is all still
the fallout from the invention of
writing itself you know it's taken to a
new level but it it's it's just another
chapter in the same story so I'm the
director of Center here at Yale which
some of you may know up and so members
of I see in the audience called the
information society project and it's
been around here since 1997 and hit
studies law and new technologies and
their effects on society we started in
1997 and we had to figure out what to
call it at Harvard they called their
Center to Berkman Center for Internet
Society there's the focus on the
internet and society I like the society
bar at Stanford they called their Center
the low center of your law on technology
ball technology at Michigan State was I
think was the Center for Law and
intellectual property okay and so this
and so when I started center ice I will
call the information society project why
because it goes back to the question of
Technology it was my bed or my
imagination that the central questions
that I wanted to address what questions
of sociality on the first part and power
and flows of information information
flows and how information is from person
to person and how people know things and
move their knowledge other people these
things were centrally related to the
oceans of society sociality and power
politics it actually turns out this is a
good bet it actually turned out that way
that when people talk about law and
technology now they're focused on the
ideas of information flows knowledge
flows in the forms of power and
sociality that coma but there are lots
of other kinds of technology right your
car hybrid car it's about power to but
sometimes it's not about information
flows or knowledge it's not about access
to knowledge and that's the reason why
it took off generally because people
were naturally attracted to thinking
about things that do a society and
relations in society and power of
society and that's why makes perfect
sense that the best technology riding
2009 would be precisely about those
questions literacy may see a little bit
of illiteracy one of the things you
learn when you study technology is the
first thing that people tell you is old
or something new nothing new and then
after having told you there's nothing
new and they ignore it and they don't
yes and the key thing that you have to
focus on people with people when you
talk about technology is to get them to
understand that what you're not
interested in is what's new you're
interested in what becomes newly salient
what features of the human condition
suddenly are put in the foreground in
ways you haven't fought before because
you change the technical or
technological assumptions go for example
let's take the question of literacy
literacy was always based on an economy
between having skills and the need to
learn new skills your hat skills you did
what you want you had new skills and
they gave you certain kinds of power and
ability there was always a choice do I
want to adopt new skills or am i five of
the skills I have similarly literacy was
also involved in economy of attention
which is how much can I digest how much
can I think about what do i do how do I
spend my time it was also an economy of
time right I only have a limited amount
of time today what can I do it was all
also the notion of your own power as a
person and your ability to relate to
others I was also kind of economy what
did the technology do the technology
change the fact that we had to worry
about these different economies no
didn't change it all still parts of the
human condition all it did was change
the balance of your adjustment of
judgement when you involve these
economies so now again when you all you
got is a book and nothing else well
basically it makes sense to economize in
focusing on that book but when you have
different kinds of possibilities then
your judgments of economy will be
different I use this term economy in two
different tenses both in the very narrow
economic sense of costs and benefits and
in the larger sense of system a social
system of relations in which you get
bound to other people by your choice of
what to spend time on by how people have
power and relationship to you the
choices you make it on how you
and what technology does is it disrupts
the existing economies of attention of
knowledge of formation of human capital
and sociality that's beautiful and I
wonder if we can follow up on a couple
of the strategies laid out for us the
from the site of those of us who study
old fashioned codex literacies it's
lately been argued that literacy in the
sense of print literacy is a is a bad
abstraction of many of the questions you
just refer to for example in the
colonial period of American history
women were routinely taught to read but
not too right so the idea of literacy is
a single skill is the first mistake we
make about it the second mistake we make
about it is the oh the overloading of
that skill concept with all kinds of
other assumptions about right
subjectivity being the right kind of
person the kind of person necessary to
run a democracy for example so Chris
Hedges the guy who wrote Wars of course
it gives us meaning has a new book
called empire of illusion all about the
loss of the the extinction of print
literacy and you know it's a kind of
apocalyptic vision of what's going to
happen now that people aren't always
reading as Stephen puts it the hallowed
400 page novel but now I think we can
see that literacy might always have been
to summon our idea literacy might always
have been to some degree the ideology of
the clerical class and and so we now
have to go back and tease out all the
different things that literacy has come
to mean and talk about why